welcome back to CBS mornings is one of
the most exciting times of the year for
us because it's Fashion Week here in New
York City and our next guest is one of
the industries you could say most
influential icon in icon is the word
Anna Wintour has been the top editor of
Vogue in the US for more than three
decades you go Anna Wintour she's also
Chief content officer for Conde Nas and
vogue's Global editorial director Vogue
magazine is marking its
130th birthday this year with a first of
its kind event it's called Vogue world
only on CBS mornings Anna winter is
ready to tell us all about it good
morning to you madam Wintour it's so
good to see you hello again to see you
Anna thank you so we're going to talk
about Vogue roll in just a second I
promise but this cover this cover just
took my breath away thank you let us
talk about Serena for just a second
number one I love her body I love the
photography and what I know about
magazine world that many people don't
know is that all this stuff is worked
out at least 3 three months ahead of
time this was way more than three so I
was wondering how long did it take for
you no Serene and I had actually been
talking about this story and you know
when she was thinking about stepping
away from tennis for well over a year
over a year and you know obviously it's
a very difficult decision for somebody
in her position with her incredible
achievements to come to that uh decision
and we would talk about it and I I felt
that we didn't really need to revisit
her career because it's so known so
recognized and we felt it would be much
better if it was in her own voice she
worked with one of our writers that she
knows to really talk about how she came
to that decision how she wanted to have
another child you know how she had such
an extraordinary business ventures in
her future but at the same time what a
tough decision it was for her to me it
was clearly very tough but when she came
to you did she come to you and say I'm
thinking about it how did that happen
she came to Vogue I think because we've
worked together for so many years I
think she felt it was the right platform
the right place for her to tell her
story and originally we thought maybe it
could be more of a straight profile but
the more we discussed it the more it
became clear to both of us that this
should be something that was in her own
voice so let's talk about Vogue world
it's your 130th anniversary how do you
feel about anniversaries because Anna
it's our year anniversary so
congratulations we only have 129 more to
keep up with you well I always just like
to look at anniversaries as a
celebration not only of the past but
also of the future and when we discuss
what we could do we were so anxious to
celebrate New York Fashion Week and also
the city itself and we thought what can
we do that will be meaningful to our
audiences and to the city as a whole so
we came together what did you come up
with we decided to do a a big street
fair meets a fashion show over 200
people on the runway 500 600 people in
the audience a live stream I think this
will be a real symbol about how New York
Fashion is back how New York City is
back and anything that we at Vogue and
con and ask and do to support that is so
important to us I am curious too Anna
about you in in terms of what you've
done at Vogue it's 34 years and I'm not
talking about the r word of retirement
I'm talking about the r word of rumors I
said I've been hearing about Anna
leaving Bogue for five years and she's
not leaving and I'm thinking why would
you leave when you still clearly seem to
be enjoying it do you see a life for
yourself after voger that's not even
something you even entertain very much
focused on the present whether it's the
Vogue world or what we'll be announcing
shortly for the next Met Gala or what
the next cover is going to be what we
can do globally for for Vogue and
colonists around the world because you
know I have such an amazing platform
Gail and it's so important to me that I
use that platform to help as many people
as I possibly can are you aware and of
the impact that you have when you walk
in a room I always say I know people
change their clothes myself included you
look great you should see well I was
trying to say I don't like this up so I
had it tucked in like this it's a great
color and Heron makeup said no no no
that looks ridiculous that looks bad I
said but Anna's coming I mean a necklace
too oh thanks but when you walk in a
room are you clocking what people are
wearing because people so hold on to
your word hold on to your your your
thought are you clocking people yourself
or not really not at all I mean not at
all like individual style I like it when
people dress like themselves and
surprising or obviously having fun with
fashion but mostly I'm interested in
them and what they have to say before
you go I'm always fascinated when I was
looking at tennis opening night there
you were in Serena's box and my eyesight
isn't that good from that far away but I
could see your signature Bob and your
sunglasses when you started that look
did you intend for it to become a
trademark or it just did no I it just
happened and you know I'm I someone
asked me about my style the other day
and I said well it's really safe verging
on boring and I I think it would be hard
for me to change at this point but also
the glasses
are very useful at times yeah oh God yes
Amen to that Anna Wintour we thank you I
know you probably can't pick a favorite
cover but this might be mine well
certainly one of my favorites one of
your favorites thank you Gail keep
soaring thank you